merci merci à tous moi je crois je crois
vous je crois aux idées je crois au
projet politique je crois que on vote
pour des projets on veut pour des
projets en région comment votre apport
d'un projet dans la dans la nation et
les socialistes en matière de projets
mais surtout en matière de résultats ont
massacré l'économie du pays hyper
fiscalisation des tas outrance chômage
de masse toujours pas inversée et
affaiblissement des collectivités
locales affaiblissement des
collectivités locales donc des régions
et nous devons absolument et noémie l'on
dit tout à l'heure
sortir de ce cycle infernal qui conduit
toujours plus d'affaiblissement du pays
tout entier
et ça commence par les régions cette
élection est une élection où tout
commence sur le plan politique mais
aussi où tout commence sur le plan
économique les régions socialistes ont
créé du chômage
elle aurait pu créer de l'emploi ça n'a
pas été le cas les nouvelles régions
sont des régions extraordinairement
puissantes
c'est une nouvelle tentative politique
c'est un terrain de développement
économique
c'est pas un terrain d'aventuré
politique évidemment et ces régions
entre une obligation celle d'abord de
générer de la croissance et celle
évidemment de créer de l'emploi à l'état
de définir les grandes lignes économique
la fiscalité la politique européenne
les les dépenses publiques
enfin bref l'ensemble de ce qui
constitue le biotope pour se développer
dans le pays
et puis aussi aux régions à elle de
créer en liaison avec les entreprises et
avec les métropoles de créer les
conditions du développement et les
régions elles permettent de rapprocher
sur un territoire très vaste donc très
puissant elles permettent de rapprocher
l'offre et la demande d'emploi
il ya beaucoup d'offres d'emploi qui ne
sont pas pourvus c'est dans les régions
qu'on pourra les rapprocher elles
permettent de rapprocher l'enseignement
supérieur l'innovation et les
entreprises elles permettent de
rapprocher les jeunes qui recherchent un
emploi qui recherchent une formation des
centres de formation des apprentis
qu'est ce qu'ils ont fait ils
socialistes ils ont fait baisser
l'apprentissage c'est probablement
quelque chose qui se voit moins que le
chômage mais c'est probablement
un crime contre l'économie encore plus
important et puis on a besoin de
rapprocher l'investissement des
entreprises qui ont besoin d'argent qui
ont besoin d'investir dans les robots
dans l'industrialisation de leur propre
boîte
et à ce moment là bien évidemment faut
se faire ce rapprochement il faut créer
des banques régionales d'investissement
il faut rapprocher les lycées du monde
professionnel sont tellement éloignés
aujourd'hui du monde professionnel on le
voit tous les jours vous connaissez des
lycéens ils sont un peu perdus dans
leurs études alors qu' il faut
évidemment les rapprocher de l'ensemble
des entreprises et en même temps créer
des infrastructures nécessaires et les
grandes régions permettront cette
création tout en équilibrant les
territoires en équilibrant les
métropoles et la ruralité auquel on
tient tant et puis enfin les régions
elles ont un rôle essentiel tout les
têtes de 10 j'imagine le diront dans le
domaine de l'agriculture
une agriculture diversifiée une
agriculture variés mais une agriculture
puissante en france
enfin moi je suis je suis candidat pour
terminer dans une dans une région
je suis candidat dans une région tête de
liste merci pour cette investiture dans
l'oise qui est la grande région nord pas
de calais picardie et c'est xavier
bertrand qui en sera le président je
n'en doute pas nous luttons contre
l'extrême droite et nous luttons contre
le lepénisme
mais en même temps nous luttons pour le
nord pas de calais picardie qui est une
région faible douze ennemis % de chômage
difficultés de santé des difficultés
d'enseignement en tout genre on a besoin
de la reconstruire
on a besoin de la redresser et c'est par
l'économie qu'on l'a redressera moi je
crois en notre capacité à changer les
choses je crois que les républiques à
allier avec lui des ihu avec le modem
pourront redresser la france mais
pourront aussi commencé par dresser les
régions vivent les régions et vive
l'avenir de notre pays